bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro skym spécial été
pendant la période estivale 50 an en
Eveline regorge d'activités en tout
genre que ce soit en extérieur ou en
intérieur pour les petits comme pour les
grands que vous soyez détente sport ou
culture vous trouverez forcément à vous
satisfaire à 51 en yeline et je vous
propose tout de suite d'en découvrir le
programme
suivez-moi
[Musique]
je vous emmène tout d'abord sur l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Yveline cet
écrin de verdure de 600 hactares se
découvre à vélo en Rosalie à pied ou à
Segou il abrite le plus grand étend
d'Île-de- France l'île est aussi une
réserve naturelle exceptionnel classé
Natura 2000 pour la rareté des espèces
sauvages animales et végétales elle
concilie préservation de la nature et
préoccupations
socio-économiques avec sa multitude
d'activités de plein air et ses
animations estivales c'est le lieu idéal
pour profiter des beaux jours que vous
soyez plutôt farniante sport culture ou
sensation en solo en famille ou entre
amis la base de loisir ravira les goûts
de tous équitation golf kayak ferme
pédagogique voile mais aussi séjour dans
le village de jourds et tipi piqueniqu
et barbecue les activités les plus
diverses sont réunies dans le plus grand
espace éducatif sportif et nature d'Île
de France le public qui vient sur l'île
de loisirs c'est avant tout
effectivement des locaux des
cinquantinois cinquantinois cquentin é
lgé évidemment également majoritairement
c'est un public iblinois
qui dépasse le périmètre de CTIN en
l'eline et puis nousous avons constaté
également que nous avons des franiliens
qui viennent sur les weekends et
vacances scolaires pour profiter des des
différentes activités au total c'est
près de 700000 visiteurs chaque année
qui viennent profiter des activités de
l'île dont 66000 rien que pour le
parcours de golf la base de loisir est
l'endroit le plus prisé des Yvelines
après le château de Versailles un succès
dû en grande partie à ses activités é
très varié et sans cesse renouvelé qui
attire un large public les visiteurs de
la base de loisirs ce sont avant tout
des groupes des groupe jeunesse des
groupes de centre de loisirs mais
également des individuels des familles
qui viennent passer la journée
l'après-midi ou bien le weekend puisque
nous avons également des youourts qui
permettent d'accueillir pour un
séjours sur plusieurs jours des
familles des familles qui pourront
profiter des activités concoctées pour
cet été avec un village sportif en
juillet avec match d'improvisation
bubble foot tir à l'arc et olympiade un
village loisir en août et un jus d' tour
du 18 au 20 juillet les plus petits eux
pourront profiter de la toute nouvelle
air de jeu d'eau durant les de mois
d'été pour les sensations fortes c'est
dans les arbres que ça se passe lîle
propose l'unique parcours aventure du
département avec un parcours sécurisé
pour les 3 6 ans de parcours de 3 et 7 m
avec baudrier dès 6 ans et deux parcours
de 12 et 15 m pour les plus de 12 ans
attraction unique en Île-de-France un
vélo suspendu dans les arbres acrophobe
s'abstenir pour les plus téméraires une
acronite sera organisé début septembre
pour une rentrée en beauté avec
maquillage fluo et lampe
[Musique]
frontale l'été c'est aussi les jeux
d'eau l'école de voile accueille près de
2600 personnes dans ses multiples les
activités voile derriiver catamaran
paddle et fitness paddle des stages sont
proposés tout l'été et encadrés par les
éducateurs sportifs du centre et pour
reprendre des forces rendez-vous au
restaurant Les alisés avec vu sur les
[Musique]
temps pour ceux qui souhaitent prolonger
l'instant plage Saint-Quentin en yeline
propose les rendez-vous été en sable à
trappe et Montini le Bretonneux on a
différentes ENF qui sont prévu sur ces 6
semaines
la semaine du 16 juillet on sera autour
du thème de la BD avec réalisation de BD
le 6 août on sera autour de la nuit de
l'observation des étoiles on aura
l'installation d'un planétarium et puis
on terminera la soirée avec
l'observation en fait du ciel donc ça
devrait être plutôt sympathique si la
BTO est avec nous autre temps fort à
Montini le Bretonneux la soirée cinéma
plein air dans le cadre de l'opération
les evvelines font leur cinéma avec la
projection du film Jurassic
dès 21h sur le site été en sable dès le
lendemain dans le cadre des arts urbains
cracheurs de feu et jongleurs viendront
animer la
ville les communes cinquantinoises
réservent encore bien des surprises cet
été de multiples animations ont lieu
dans les maisons de quartier de
guillencour et au pied des habitations à
La Verrière les mercredis de l'été au
clés sous-bois propose des activités
pour les enfants et les familles
Villepreux ouvre sa piscine chauffée
tout tout l'été jusqu'au 30 août
coignère elle invite les 11 17 ans au
gymnase du moulin avant pour des
activités sportives jeux de société
soirée à thème et veillé mais aussi du
bowling de la piscine une sortie au parc
Astérix mais pas seulement on est
inscrit sur des dispositifs qui sont le
crossif qui est le comité régional
olympique sportif Île-de-France donc il
y a deux dispositifs qui nous proposent
pour cet été opération sauvenage et
sport en fi au menu il y a différentes
activités sport de proposer ainsi que
des
ateliers de
secourisme des ateliers de citoyenneté
qui sont proposés sur ces journées là
sans oublier un séjour en Ardèche de son
côté Manil etamoau privilégient les
activités de pleinir sous le signe des
légumes morpa propose sa 2e édition de
MPa estival et pour plaisir ce sera la
18e édition de la Nuit des étoiles quant
à voisin le Bretonneux ce sera tournoi
sportif et sorti sur le thème de la
glisse de la glisse il en sera question
tout l'été puisque les nombreuses
piscines que compte l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin restent
ouverte pour les plus studieux qui
recherchent des vacances plus
culturelles Saint-Quentin en Yveline la
bellisée ville d'art et d'histoire
possède de nombreuses œuvres d'art
disséminées un peu partout dans les
parcs et jardins plusieurs rallyies parc
et nature de 8 à 13 km sont proposés par
le musée de la ville le premier parcours
est en avant l'art dans la ville et
traverse le quartier de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline et le parc des sources de la
Bièvre entre ville et nature le deuxième
est basé sur le thème Promenons-nous
dans les années 70 et il prend sa source
à hlencour dans le quartier des se mars
et le parc des coudraai entre l'urbain
et le parc le dernier parcours
patrimoine art et nature est aussi le
plus long 13 km en partant du quartier
de Saint-Quentin jusqu'aux trois
villages vers la Sourderie à av le parc
des sources de la Bièvre un rally très
vert à travers les sentes
cinquantinoises et pour poursuivre sur
le chemin de l'art et de l'histoire à
Saint-Quentin je vous invite à vous
rendre au musée de Port Royal des champs
à Manil etamo un musée situé au cœur
d'un parc de 30 hectares un lieu entre
culture et
nature le Domaine de Port Royal s'étend
sur 30 hectares en lisière de forêt vous
y apprécierz les balades entre champs et
bois l'occasion de découvrir le
patrimoine historique remarquable du
site Port Royal c'est aussi une abbaylie
et un musée situé au sein d'un parc qui
abrite un ancien corps de ferme dans les
jardins vous pourrez découvrir le verger
historique des granges entièrement
écologique et reconstitué tel qu'il
était au 17e siècle entre musée et
jardin plor d'activités attendent les
petits comme les grands cet été nous
avons comme chaque été depuis une
dizaine d'années les ateliers qui
permettent d'accueillir les enfants des
centres de loisirs et principalement les
enfants des quartiers pour une visite
animée du musée et du site des ruines le
matin une pièce de théâtre à midi un
grand pique-nique et puis l'après-midi
des ateliers pédagogiques de pratiques
artistiques le théâtre la poterie la
peinture ou des ateliers nature euh
découvertes de l'environnement
découvertees des plantes
ça c'est pour les plus jeunes et pour
les grands pendant le mois de juillet
l'exposition Rosa Bonheur continue elle
fermera le 25 juillet c'est l'occasion
de profiter de ces premiers jours de
vacances pour voir ou revoir les œuvres
de cet artiste qui a illustré la
peinture animalière et dont la famille a
été pendant plusieurs générations des
habitants de la commune de Manil et
amameau
[Musique]
et si cet été vous souhaitez jouer les
Glob trotur à travers la France entière
surtout restez à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est à hlencour que ça se passe
sur le site de France Miniature qui fête
cet été ses 25 ans vous avez votre sac à
dos alors on y va de l'abbaye de
Saint-Antoine en iserre à la cathédrale
d'ALB dans le Tarne en passant par la
Tour Effel et versaill jusqu'à la cité
médiévale de Carcasson il n'y a qu'un
pas ou presque France Miniature c'est un
parc de 5 haectares strictement dessiné
à la forme de la France sur lequel vous
allez retrouver 117 monuments et
villages français tout se reproduit au
130e mais aussi 14 ateliers interactifs
une grotte préhistorique un chantier de
fouille archéologique pour découvrir de
petits trésors à emporter et h
attractions pour plus de sensations
fortes on accueille 170000 visiteurs par
an alors le public typique de France
Miniature sont des gens qui viennent en
famille l'an dernier 70 % de nos
visiteurs sont venus en famille avec des
enfants qui ont entre 5 et 12 ans plus
de 30 % de notre clientèle l'an dernier
avait moins de 11 ans pour son 25e
anniversaire France Miniature réserve
bien des surprises à ses visiteurs entré
à 15 € pour tout le monde des
réservations sur le site et moins 25 %
pour les 50tinois gratuité totale si
vous êtes né en
1991 et avez vous aussi 25 ans pour les
enfants des ateliers gratuits autour des
abeilles tous les mercredis de juillet
vous saurez tout sur le miel la cire et
comment fabriquer vos bougies ainsi
qu'une toute nouvelle attraction dès le
20 juillet suspense
suspense et si d'aventure le soleil
venait à bouder quelques journées d'été
pas de panique de la séance ciné à la
salle de mur d'escalade en passant par
le kting et le bouling de nombreuses
activités en intérieur sont proposé pour
vous faire oublier le mauvais temps et
vous redonner le sourire les nombreuses
salles de cinéma de saquentin en yeline
propose une programmation diversifiée
tout l'été pour tous les publics à
l'espace Philippe Noiret aux clés
sousbois au ciné 7 à hencour à l'UGC
Ciné City Sky West et à la salle
jacquesbrell de Montini le Bretonneux
sans oublier le grenier à celle de
trappe au clés sous-bois vous pourrez
vous adonner au bowling au billard ou au
karting au sein du speed Park à Montini
le brotonux vous pourrez affronter les
murs d'escalade du vertical art quant
aux enfants ils pouront vont se défouler
à l'Universal circuit de morpa au Royal
Kids d'lancour ou encore au kinguru by
Ludy max à villepr vous pouvez aussi
partager vos bons plans cuisine lecture
bricolage ou jardinage sur les réseaux
sociaux de C en yeline n'oubliez pas
également que de nombreuses structures
municipales demeurent ouvertes tout
l'été afin de vous accueillir et de vous
proposer des animations thématiques
gratu je vous souhaite un très bel été à
SaintQuentin en Eveline
Ciao
[Musique]